đại hại chính trong cuộc đời của người danh ông.
Câu chuyện thú vị từ R.D.N.O.
A R.D.N.O. vừa tung ra mộ sư tập tú đông
hai khung hai là mang tên kết nổi yển thoại
cũng mô anh khiến xanh tình không khỏi tò mò.
Vấn sứ phòng các tình đếc quan thuộc như là này
hình anh được thể hiện nghiệp thuật vào cảm xúc hơn
tả hiệp trọn vẹn khi chất của một kuy ông vừa lịch lắm vừa phòng khán
lấy cảm hữu từ đại hại chính vất lợp
mộ sư tập kể lại công chuyện về người danh ông qua bà dễ đoạn của người
áp uu trình bị ra khơi, máy nhà là điểm kởi của nơi ước mơ được ước mơm,
trình bị chính là khoảng thời gian tô liện mạnh lĩnh
và quy cùm ra khơi là núc giấn tên vào lým trên thời mời
người khác phọng thành công được hiện tình quá
hạ tích đàn lắp su tiện như sợ chỉ kết nổi
quan bộ thiết kể, hốn định nổi trong văn quá kện nằm
đàn lát khi được đưa vòng ngôn lữ thời trang
lại mang đến một sĩnh mạo khác, giịt đại, không khoảng
nhưng vẫn lưu giữ sửa thân thuộc, hạ tích vừa gợi nớt
mọi người, vừa khả định sự sáng tạo không lưng của Aristinot
Nếu là mêng sự khách định của Aristinot, chính là chức lý
tởi trang gắn liền với văn quá, mối tiếp kế không chỉ đề mạc
mắt con đề kế một câu chuyện về hàng trình sống, về bản lượng
và khách phọng của người đàn ông hiện đại, ít nổi quyền thoại
vì thế không đơn thuận là bộ sức tập thử trang,
mà là nguồn cạo hữu trẻ quý ông tìm thấy mình trong tình bức đi
tư tổng ở vương trái đến miệnh lớn thành công